Dan Attias, Director, Producer
and Author:So we light the
master and we get ready to call
everybody, we do the master angle
he comes in does it the same way. So
now I’m thinking Oh boy, all right.
Film Courage: How to get
the best out of your actors?
Dan: Directing actors I would identify as the
most important responsibility of the director.
Of course there's many, many other things.
One is responsible for as the director
but let me read what I wrote.
Film Courage: Your book is right there.
Dan: This is my book Directing Great
Television and I have a chapter on
directing actors which is the second
longest chapter in the book. The other
is on the language of camera. Let me just
read the opening of it and then I’ll maybe
take off from that and summarize some of
the things I do discuss. I start the chapter
“Watching a great performance take shape
is one of the true thrills of directing.
Something emerges that is deep and revealing about
being human. Helping your cast get there is among
the director's most important responsibilities.
Some projects are more actor dependent than others
but in my experience a story's impact is
directly related to how much truthfulness,
emotional honesty and depth of understanding
the actors bring to their performance.
That's not to say that every character
is truthful, honest or deep, quite the
contrary but actors who have accessed those
qualities in themselves are in a better position
to enrich the story.” I think that's so true
because I know as I'm watching something
if I feel the actor is in touch with something
true and interesting, if I'm drawn to that actor
because there's something compelling about who
they are because they're fully online let's say
fully in touch with something deep that they're
working with the story I mean that's that's what
I think typifies almost any great performance
doesn't mean they're intense it doesn't mean
anything else they could be putting up a front
they could be disaffected characters but there
but there's an inner life that leads to that
kind of expression and the actors need the
best performances are those who've filled in
that inner life so that it's coming it's like
a deep well of of experience that just manifests
in this this one way as opposed to saying well I'm
disaffected so I'm just going to be disaffected
I'm not going to feel anything you you might be
feeling a lot of work not to feel something
as opposed to just not feeling something so
getting the performance is is is
a great responsibility and a great
experience I find and every actor is different
every many directors are frightened of actors
they they feel like they're different species well
they're not they're they're human beings there's
there's a whole range of cliches about
actors that they might be narcissistic or
self-important or overly dramatic or whatever
and and some of them are just like directors
just like anybody but really what your job is as
director is to help the direct help the actor uh
be able to utilize their particular process
how they work and so that it involves kind of
reading each human being that you're approaching
to direct for who they are and how you can connect
to them it's a very intimate intimate experience
and I found it's a big big topic and I can't
but I think that some of the things I can
just briefly touch on is I think first of all
you need to develop trust with an actor because
you're asking them to you want to share you want
them to invite you into their process so so if
they don't trust you they're not likely to do that
so in in to be trustworthy I find you also have
to be as authentic as possible so I try to because
I want an authentic performance from them also
so I have to if if nothing else I have to model
that I'm willing to be authentic I want you to
be willing to be authentic and it also helps to
it helps to elicit trust um different
actors need different things different
actors some sometimes they need to be acquainted
with the imaginary circumstances sometimes they
haven't defined what's at issue in a way that is
consonant with your understanding of the story
or they haven't enriched their character's
inner life as much as you'd like them to
do so sometimes you're involved in in
helping them with that the one thing
you don't want to do is is to tell them exactly
how to do something and there's a there's a kind
of a just become kind of a bromide about
don't give result directions meaning like
do it angry well you might want that to be the
ultimate outcome of their performance but you're
cutting them off from their impulses you have to
give them a reason for why you have to justify
that because you want it to feel like real human
behavior the other thing about telling an actor
how to do something is you're you're communicating
to them that you don't trust their own instincts
and that's that's the worst thing it's like what
I'm always trying to do is is to invite the actor
to explore themselves and make it truthful
for them I'll do whatever I can to acquaint
them with what what i'd like them to explore but
if they're not connected to an inter and inner
to their own inner resources then you might
get them to do a particular moment the way
you tell them to do it but what about the next
moment and and and also they're probably not
connected to their scene partners because they're
thinking about doing something a particular way
and it's when when actors aren't connected
to their scene partners you generally feel
it it's hard to fake connection you want
that kind of moment-to-moment connectivity
and you want to provide then another thing you
want to work on with actors it's always very
helpful I find there's a there's a cliche about
that people have a lot of fun with with the actor
saying what's my motivation well yeah you can have
a lot of fun with that but the reality is that's
kind of the key question an actor needs
to ask and also a director needs to ask
and actors need to be aware I like to think
of think of it this way that it's important
to know a character's motivations on a lot
of levels of the character's own awareness
for example example I said in the book too it's
like if if a character wants to impress his boss
or her boss it may be that's one level of a motive
but it may be it's really his father he wants
to impress in a deeper level so that there's
gradations of there's depths of intentionality
what are some of the other things another thing is
you have to be willing to um take responsibility
in a way you have to be you have to be willing
to deliver a note that might not be easy to
do if you're going to ask an actor to change the
way they're thinking about it I mean it helps of
course as I say to gain trust to gain their good
will but often you you can be in a situation
where an actor has made a choice that's just not
appropriate for what you think the story is and
one of the one of the ways I approach that
often is I try to share with the actor
where a particular moment in the story is falling
there is an example I cite in the book from
an episode of homeland I directed called 13 hours
in Islamabad which was a very intense episode
and I was working with Mandy Patinkin who is one
of the most intuitive sensitively attuned actors
with whom i've ever worked he's very method and
he's very goes in deep place within himself and
and Mandy will actually say this
early in his career he was often
pretty intractable and was not
very open to directors giving them
advice about that he said I know how I want
to play this he's he's mellowed a lot in
that regard and as as it's been brilliant in
homeland well in this particular episode um
let's see what's happened leading up to the scene
is Isis has kind of taken over this as it overrun
the packet the American embassy in Pakistan killed
37 Americans it's a complete disaster and the
reason they were able to do it was because Saul
Mandy's character had been captured by isis and
he had been used as a bargaining chip to draw
out the forces from the embassy to to affect
the prisoner exchange so isis knew and that's I
don't think it was called isis in the show but
a stand-in for terrorist organization knew that
the embassy was not sufficiently guarded and then
they had gotten other information so it and Saul
blames himself for having gotten captured because
he was inattentive he did something he shouldn't
have done he got oh he got lured into a trap
that he punishes himself for not having figured
out so it's the night of it's the night of this
thing it's just happened it's a complete disaster
everybody is in their own personal crisis and Saul
is being debriefed by Rupert friends character um
I'm blanking on his character's name but so Rupert
is interrogating Saul and Carrie Claire Dane's
character is watching the interrogation and it was
a very intense six or seven page sequence I asked
for an hour I asked for a rehearsal in advance of
the call time because I knew there was going
to be a lot to really work out moment to moment
so I asked for an hour long I mean people who do
features might think an hour that's nothing but
if I could get an hour that was
that was it would have to be enough
so I asked the actors to come in
an hour before crew call and we'd
try to work out all the nuances and so the shape
of the scene was that Rupert who has witnessed his
compatriots executed and is is just in a mania
of trying to capture haqqani who is the lead
terrorist he's got to have something to go on and
he's he's interrogating Saul what what did you see
when you were in captivity give me something
give me something i've got to find this guy
and Saul is bereft and he's he says I didn't see
anything I was hooded the whole time he said okay
well and and the windows are blacked out and
and Rupert says well what about the phones the
cell phones that they gave you says they were
changed out every day I don't know what telephones
and Rupert gets furious at Saul and yells
at him is you have to do better you have to
stop give me something give me something and
Mandy's reaction in the first rehearsal was
rage he just stood up to Rupert and just yelled
how can I see how could I know what I didn't
see and he yells at him and and Mandy Patinkin
is capable of unbelievable power and fury now
what's supposed to happen at this point is Claire
Danes is supposed to enter she's outside of this
this safe room it's glass walls but she can't hear
what's going on but she sees what's happening and
she comes into the room and she says to Rupert
friend we've got to talk and they'd go outside
so we we rehearsed the scene and I knew that
Mandy had made this choice he preps very hard
and he thought a lot about it and I knew well it's
powerful it's legitimate he's punishing himself
for he's very upset with himself it's legitimate
in terms of his character choice but it's not
right for this moment in the scene because for
this moment in the scene the story point we're
trying to give the audience is that Rupert has
become so monomaniacally attached to vengeance
that he's becoming a bit inhuman himself and he's
going to take some terrible risks both for himself
and for others in this episode and in future
episodes so we wanted to cue the audience to
this happening to seeing what's happening within
him and Carrie intervenes because she has seen
Rupert rupert's excessiveness how he's
hitting a man when he's already down
but but Saul wasn't down Mandy wasn't down so
I talked to Mandy and I knew this is going to
be difficult because Mandy is likely feels very
strongly about this and I don't want to throw
not that he wouldn't be cooperative he
would have wanted to do it but I didn't
want to throw a wrench into his performance I
didn't want to cut him off from his instincts
so I said to Mandy here's here's our problem I
understand that what that's another thing I do
when I'm trying to make adjustments that I want
an actor to feel seen I want them to know that I
saw what they were trying to do there's nothing
I think it's dispiriting to tell an actor yeah
I don't do it that way do this way they may have
given a lot of thought to what they did they have
made and they're and most of them are not stupid
people and if you don't acknowledge what you saw
them do and just say it doesn't make you writing
them wrong it's just a difference of opinion
so what I'll tend to try to do is say I see
what you were doing how you were trying to
affect your scene partner in this particular way
i'd like to i'd like you to think about this in a
little different way and i'd give them different
imaginary circumstances hoping to kind of
orient them more towards what the story
needs to be with Mandy I told him I said
here's our problem it's very justified what you
did for Saul's behavior but it's not the story
point and I told him the story point is as I
just stated that we've got to feel that Rupert
is hitting you when you're down if you stand up to
him with such ferocity that we've always expected
from you you might your rage might outstrip his
and we wouldn't get that feeling also with Carrie
coming in it's going to render that whole thing
differently motivated it's going to be confusing
and I saw he understood oh that's the story
and it's interesting to me also that it's not
the actor's responsibility to know how their
choices are affecting other story lines or
other characters that's your responsibility
as a director but then what has to happen is
you need to find a solution that upholds the
integrity of all the characters you can't
then ask somebody to play play it falsely for
your character just so this happens that's not
good directing you've got to
be imaginative enough to find
a way to suggest a way that they can identify
oh I see that would be a legitimate choice too
so I told Mandy this I said as near as I can
recall by season four we had never seen Mandy
filled with any kind of serious self-doubt
or doubt in his own powers or his own
fierceness and I said I think what would be very
moving here would be if you if you're willing to
go to a place of deep deep depression like a real
dark night of the soul if you really can take in
that your inattention led to a slaughter of
37 human beings and the loss of all of the
american contacts undercover context throughout
pakistan if you can not forgive yourself for that
if you can just be constantly punishing yourself
internally for it that you don't have to fight
at this point to oppose him that would do several
things it would make his relentless attack on you
a very different matter and would highlight
what's happening within Rupert's character
so if you're willing to consider the scene that
way I think I think we've got it and he took it
in and he understood it and because I think he
understood the story he was able to adjust his
own performance and what's so fascinating to me is
when you deal with really wonderful actors and you
appeal to them this way they become collaborators
and can enrich your thoughts your ideas beyond
whatever you might have thought of in a later
scene because of this particular note he had
taken in he found the most poetically beautiful
way to play a scene he was taking a shower and
he just water pounding down on him he just chose
and he just chose to just stare right down at the
floor as water is hitting him and it's like it was
so beautiful and so poetic and I knew Mandy had
taken it in and accessed his incredible resources
to really find the depth of the depth of the scene
so as you said letting them feel seen
knowing that you that you saw them that
you saw what they were trying to do and it wasn't
necessarily a bad thing but how about we try this
and this is something that this is always done
in private or just time not allow for that well
no that is something one has to be sensitive to
that you don't want an actor to feel shown up
but generally I'm hoping yeah and I'll try to of
course give notes whenever I can sonovoche or in
private but sometimes my note giving is actually
giving a note to another actor who's hearing it
so sometimes it's like I want it to be public
because I want everybody in the scene I might take
it as an opportunity to define what the scene's
about and I know that it might good actors are
kind of hearing that they might play into that
that's again enlisting their cooperation and
listening their talent to they might find other
wrinkles in the way they're going to do so some
so often I like giving a note publicly because
I'm really addressing everybody because I'm
talking about bigger issues so so that's that's
one thing but I will say there are times when it's
it's a little concerning giving a note especially
when you're dealing with like an intimidating
actor and I had one story again I relate in
the book that just show us your book it's got
a beautiful cover thank you it's directing
great television inside tv's new golden age
there was an instance where I took a job on a
show which will remain nameless not because I
think the actor would really mind the story I'm
going to tell but I just want to be cautious on it
he was an actor very famous actor and I i took
the job primarily to work with him I thought oh
my goodness I he's he's i've been blown away
by his performances and so many things and
when I was prepping another thing I'll do with
actors is as I try to avoid a situation where I'm
showing up on set to direct them never having met
them because it's like that's that's one of the
really interesting challenges of directing series
television is you're the one temporary person
and yet you're in command you're coming into
leading and being the final arbiter and when the
performance is good enough to say cut move on and
they may not even know you or know anything about
you or know it's like how can I trust this person
do I know they even have a grasp of the show
so I try never to it doesn't always work sometimes
you can't meet everybody before but I try and
prep to go introduce myself maybe talk a little
bit about the script if they're lead characters
try to acquaint them with the fact that I know
that i've seen the show and talk about what
i've admired about them and all that and I'll
also say while on this subject often when I'm
giving notes to actors on show new or shows
where I'm new and they don't really know me
I'll try to couch my adjustments by referencing
other shows other of their performances so they
see I said this moment is interesting it reminds
me a little bit about that moment in season two
where you had that scene with so and so there's
a lot of similarities to that in this this moment
here where your intention there was more this
kind of thing I think that's kind of more what's
at play here than necessarily trying to do this
other thing but the difference is and so suddenly
they're hearing me oh oh they've watched both
shows oh I get okay I think it can build trust
but in this instance I went to introduce myself
to this lead actor I'll call him I call him the
book I call him max so I'll just say his name
is max and I went up to him and I just it was
one of those things where you're talking to kind
of a an I someone who's kind of a acting hero of
yours and you're he's and I said oh I really am
looking forward to working to you and all that
and as I'm talking to him he had this manner of
this kind of preternatural calm he was just so
self-possessed so unaffected by anything I was
saying he just was looking at me and I felt like
I felt like I was being looked through and I felt
like what am I doing here I'm trying to impress
somebody or it's like he's he's not impressed and
he didn't it was very unforthcoming he was polite
but so I left it was one of those instances where
you think oh my god what did I say was it that
oh my god that was stupid so I didn't feel the
comfort you hope to get when you're introducing
yourself and so I went through my prep and then
the first scene we had together was the scene I
was really looking forward to him doing because
I oh he's gonna kill this it's to be great and
we rehearse it and he comes in and he gives the
most tepid uninteresting performance imaginable
worse it was boring and I'm just watching
this and what and I think to myself okay
just remember this is just a run through this
is a rehearsal maybe his process is not to act
at the beginning maybe it's okay and I don't
want to be come to him and say max I think he's
what are you talking about it wasn't what are
you judging me for it wasn't my performance I
didn't want that right so I said I'm going to just
wait and we'll shoot it and then I'll see what he
brings so we light the master and we get ready to
call everybody we do the master angle he comes in
does it the same way so now I'm thinking oh boy
all right so now my first scene with this guy
I have to go to him and completely tell him his
instincts are completely off from what I want
and I'm thinking and I'm also not sure what he
thinks about me and so I'm thinking okay what
can I do now so I think hard long and hard about
it and for the viewers to understand the note
I gave him I have to just tell you a little bit
about the scene max's character was the leader of
a band of renegades thieves wasn't james
gandolfini this is not the sopranos
and and he's a fierce ruthless character and the
person he's coming in to see is someone and he has
his own community of thieves they have a their
own world and the person he is coming in to see
is someone who had an aristocratic background
who had to flee because he was at his own trouble
and had sought refuge with max's world
and has been there now for several years
and what he's tasked with the the other guy is
tasked with doing is fixing a piece of machinery
that max needs fixed to accomplish his grand
criminal scheme he this has to be repaired for
him to be able to do this thing and he comes
into the scene and he says how is it going
and the other guy who also is sickly so
he's not very well but he says this is
really I don't know if I can fix this it's really
difficult and max then begins to spin the tale of
their history and he says when you first
came here I thought you were an aristocratic
man who really looked down on people like us rough
young men who kind of brought ourselves up by our
own bootstraps and all that he goes on a little
more he says but as the years have gone by i've
i've seen that you've you've assisted us
and all that and I really hope that you'll
work harder to get this done that
was paraphrased of what happens and
what max had done is he had taken the
surface level of the dialogue literally
and he played it very docily respectfully
and come in and said all this thing very
nicely and inviting him to really work harder
and I went to max and I said okay I said
i wonder if I could ask you to think
about this scene a little differently
the contempt you describe having
felt for him when he first
arrived i'd like you still to be
feeling exactly the same thing
oh look I didn't say it any more than that but the
anyway so I'll say so he just
looked at me and said very well
and I go back to the to watch it and we say
action as soon as he comes in there was just
an electric vibration it was chilling it was
terrifying he came in and he started to talk
to this guy how is it coming and then he starts
to tell the tale of their history and what you
understood in the subtext is I thought you were
an entitled [ __ ] then and I still think that
and just because we've existed coexisted
because there's been mutual benefit
if that mutual benefit should ever end your life
isn't worth a cent and that was this I mean this
intensity he had it was just terrifying he was
always just toying with him and talking about it
and it was everything I thought the scene should
be it was just electrifying it was fantastic
so we cut and we move on and we play the scene no
nothing more from from max I do that max that was
great thank you whatever and and so a few days
later I'm in the I do I do my laundry at the
at the costumers the wardrobe trailer where they
clean their clothes there's washing machines I
bring mine in and they throw it in and the head
costumer approaches me and said hey I was talking
to you about I was talking about you with max
and immediately I'm a little unalert because I'm
thinking I have no idea if he agreed with my note
or what he thinks about me or anything so I said
and she said yeah he says he loves working with
you you're the first director to give him a note
and I just realized that other directors great
direct great actors might rarely need notes but
sometimes they do and if you're the storyteller
they almost always will will benefit from shadings
or something to kind of point them more but I
think his his presence was so intimidating to
some directors they just felt I'm that's above my
pay grade I actually heard one director actually
said that and that's irresponsible it's tough
but you got to be willing to stand up for what
you think the story point is and find ways to do
it that and take a risk maybe someone you really
admire is going to be really unhappy with you and
yell at you but that's the buck stops with you.